here's a nice logarithm question if a
plus b is equal to root 7 and a minus B
is equal to root 3 what is log base a of
b equal to
solve this problem work out the values
of A and B add the two equations and
divide by two to get the value of a
subtract the two equations and divide by
two to get the value of B
now let's work out the reciprocal of B
multiply the numerator and denominator
by root seven plus root 3 the
denominator then simplifies and this all
works out to be exactly equal to a
so 1 over B is equal to a 1 over a is
equal to B so log base a of B is equal
to log base a of one over a which is
equal to log base a of a to the negative
1 and that gives the answer of negative
one